there's a new facility in town for
animals right here in las vegas it's a
hospital just for our furry felines
bianca holman has our story
cats are unique lovable but often
independent it can be a challenge for
some owners to get them to the vet but
there's a new hospital to solve this
issue over the last year i have noticed
that there's been an increasing number
of cats
seen at animal hospitals
and i wanted a place where we could see
cats that
could alleviate some fear some anxiety
for those those individual cats this
facility summerlin cat hospital is
different grooming boarding and of
course health care dr defare and her
teen use certain tactics to help cats
relax for a stress-free visit cats need
special attention especially when it
comes to preventative care hats are very
stoic
so it's not that they hide pain it's
just that they are less
likely or quickly to show pain such as
dogs and humans dr defara says yearly
checkups are important because most
diseases are caught on basic exams i
love seeing cats thrive i love seeing
kittens and then as they get older it's
just fun to kind of watch their
transformation and treat them year after
year bianca holman live local now